I'm actually like really straight in
here
what's up everyone my name is toy and
welcome to making it big the show where
my friends challenged me to make their
favorite foods big so if you notice that
my table is a little warped here that's
because we're filming everything with a
VR camera very fancy if you want to
watch the full VR episode you can with a
meta Quest 2 in mega tasty that's our
virtual cooking world within Horizon
world or on metaquest TV so today I have
my favorite person here soybean
hey welcome to the kitchen excited to be
here excited to challenge you let's see
what it is to match my outfit today
Takis did you know that these are my
favorite maybe a hint or two but also
they're one of my favorite chips how big
do you want this so knowing you usually
you like to take the challenge and up it
even more right big personality big
everything but I want you to try to make
this like a baseball bat I want to be
able to get a big swing out of it so big
as a baseball bat Fuego flavor Fuego how
important is the crunch for you super
important that crunch Factor needs to be
because that's that's the most important
part of takis right like you hear people
yeah all right thanks bud I have a lot
of work to do I will see you later
hopefully with giant talkies good job
buddy thank you okay guys
let's make this big all right giant
Takis so that means giant tortilla now
I'm kind of nervous because I have never
made a tortilla from scratch before so
to make a big one is um kind of scary I
have salt right here I have some
vegetable oil here
so I'm using hot water because it slows
the gluten formation it makes the
tortilla not puff up like we don't want
this to be bread we want this to be a
tortilla it smells like the mollusk
right now
[Music]
so when I moved from Vietnam to America
we moved to a town called Oxnard it was
a culture shock that I didn't know I was
going to experience like I didn't really
experience white culture like that but I
did experience a lot of Mexican culture
because all of my friends were Mexican
so for my first ever Christmas
I didn't know that like tamales was a
thing on Christmas and now every year on
Christmas I have to have tamales because
it's just not the same without it okay
that feels pretty good to me I'm gonna
oh
let's get my hands in here
I think we are ready for an ASMR moment
[Music]
okay so this is the Takis Fuego flavor
and I'm looking at the back of it just
to find what I need for the seasoning I
think I'm ready to rock and roll let's
do our habanero right here cayenne
pepper
garlic powder onion powder paprika chili
powder add some sugar in here I'm really
hoping that all of these powders and
spices will make my Takis taste like
Takis
because that's important I need to I
really need to deliver for soy
and again the reason why I'm adding this
coloring is because I know that if I
don't the color is not going to be
vibrant enough and
oh it's kidding me
hold
all right let's get back to where it
needs to look exactly like the Takis
that you see when you open up the bag oh
this is probably the most satisfying
moment for me
just seeing all of the colors
just gonna
oh that tastes like a Taki all I gotta
do now is grind it up into a finer
powder
I'm going through it Fuego oh
if you ever attempt to make Takis at
home make sure that you have a mask
[Music]
huh
so it just doesn't look like it's
getting to the Fine powder that I'm
looking for because this coating right
here is really really fine and it's it's
just not what I'm looking for
I have something the world's smallest
spice grinder
[Music]
all right this is definitely what I'm
looking for
yeah
that's good stuff
[Music]
okay my dough has been rested and I did
the math this dough right here will make
approximately six giant donkeys
perfect
[Music]
it looks like Patrick's Star right now
[Music]
the middle is kind of
well this is not an oval that I'm hoping
for but since we're going to be rolling
it I kind of don't mind it it's also my
first one all right
this is super delicate be really slow
and gentle with it I think this is the
hardest step
oh
this is my first giant Takis
that's gonna go into the oven at 350 for
an hour
[Music]
all right so this is our big giant
talkies can you guys see me this is
cooked all the way through but it's not
crispy I need it to really crisp and
have that crunch
when we bite into it so to the fryer I
go
here we go
okay that was really peaceful thank you
for that the color looks incredible
[Music]
here you go
[Music]
yep that feels crunchy
here we go so I really want to pack in
the powder
are you serious look at this
it's kind of taking everything in me
right now to not take a bite let's let's
call Soy and have her come in sooner
rather than later because this might not
be here later
super proud of what we've created I just
really hope that soy loves it soybean
toy sure open my eyes wait wait wait
wait wait okay come here I wanted the
surprise Factor you know yeah okay ready
yeah three two one
God you got the bag too yeah that's
crazy shout out to our department do you
want to hold one I would love to hold
yeah as many as I can
I'ma get one for me too it's a little
flute so size did I pass 100 like I feel
like I can
um the looks of it
it's like perfect I feel like an ant
like you know when you see like a giant
talkie that's what I feel like yeah
that's amazing
foreign
[Music]
oh that is spicy yeah I can feel the
heat now the flavor tastes exactly like
the Takis like I don't know how you did
it
[Music]
Wow saving this for later look how red
our hands are this is like the best
um
foreign
[Music]